et retour en france cinq ans après la
mort d'anna matra aurait étouffé par les
gendarmes lors de son interpellation sa
soeur à ça continue de réclamer justice
de la mairie de personnes jusqu'à celle
de beaumont sur oise dans le val d'oise
lieu de l'interpellation en fatale du
jeune homme de 24 ans en 2016 le
collectif qui réclame justice pour adama
traoré et ses soutiens se sont
rassemblés pour une nouvelle marche
contenu
de nouveaux témoignages et éléments
médicaux recueillis par les recueillir
par les enquêteurs et juges
d'instruction chargés d'affaires ont
tant donné un complément d'expertisé
médicale qui pourrait engager la
responsabilité des gendarmes des
gendarmes décoré par un patronat
gendarmerie nationale en 2019 pour je
cite service exceptionnel une honte
dénoncé à cette fin un brillant
l'écoutent de la mort de son frère
cinq ans après robien sentiment
d'injustice
cinq ans après la vérité la justice n'a
toujours pas été retrouvé à la pompe à
damas alors que nous avons tous les
éléments qui sont là et qui prouve que
les gendarmes sont responsables de la
mort de mon petit frère
nous avons cette expertise qui va sortir
en janvier cette expertise qui a été
mandaté par la justice française par des
experts belges qui vont dire que les
gendarmes sont responsables de la mort
d'adama traoré pendant l'interpellation
nous avons l'impression qu'une pression
est mise sur les gens et les experts en
belgique pour qu'ils puissent changer
leur avis nous demandons avec notre
avocat maître yassine bouzrou maintenons
une autre famille la mise en examen de
six gendarmes